y
[Música]
iniciaron las deliberaciones del jurado
en el juicio contra el ex policía de
minneapolis derecha bin acusado de
asesinar a la faa mericano george floyd
en mayo de 2020 los 12 integrantes del
jurado continuarán hoy con las
deliberaciones en medio de protestas de
fuertes medidas de seguridad
armin la 7 es el candidato oficial de la
unión democratacristiana la cancillería
de alemania la colectividad a la cual
pertenece la actual canciller angela
merkel presentó la candidatura de la
chet después de que el líder de la cs un
marcus oda diera un paso al costado
tenemos reportes desde berlín
y el presidente de cuba miguel
díaz-canel y fue confirmado como primer
secretario general del partido comunista
el nombramiento marca el fin de los
casos en el poder después de 60 años
mientras la nación insular atraviesa su
peor crisis económica agravada por la
pandemia tenemos análisis
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en las 24 mi
nombre es liliana valència gracias por
estar con nosotros comenzaron las
deliberaciones del jurado en el juicio
contra derecha bin señalado de asesinar
al afroamericano georg floyd el jurado
tendrá que decir por unanimidad si yo
vine el ex agente de policía blanco es
inocente o culpable mientras en las
calles los ciudadanos exigen justicia
sobre el hecho que quedó registrado en
vídeo y provocó una ola de
manifestaciones global en contra del
racismo y la brutalidad policial el
siguiente informe revisamos los
argumentos de la fiscalía y también de
la defensa
en ese caso pueden creer lo que ven sus
ojos ese es el principal argumento de la
fiscalía en el caso contra derecho ven
para tratar de convencer al jurado de
que el ex policía es culpable
este caso es exactamente lo que ustedes
piensan cuando lo vendo cuando por
primera vez vieron el vídeo pueden creer
lo que ven sus ojos es exactamente lo
que creen es exactamente lo que saben lo
que sienten instintivamente es lo que
saben ahora en su corazón
eso no fue ejercer como policía fue
asesinato la fiscalía argumenta que
georg klein murió asfixiado por falta de
oxígeno cuando el entonces policía
directo a bing se arrodilló sobre su
cuello durante nueve minutos como es
posible ver en este vídeo que se hizo
viral e hizo estallar en protestas a
eeuu y al mundo entero en contra de la
violencia policial la defensa sin
embargo quiere descartar ese argumento
asegurando que floyd consumía drogas y
tenía antecedentes de salud
sólo quieren que ignoren los importantes
problemas médicos que el señor floyd
tenía y el fracaso de los expertos del
estado en reconocer cualquier
posibilidad de que esos otros factores
contribuyeron en alguna manera a la
muerte del señor floyd
anyway lo que desafía la ciencia el
sentido común y la razón
bajo el temor de que se repita las
protestas del año pasado minneapolis
está en alerta máxima mientras espera el
veredicto en manos de 12 miembros del
jurado que están aislados para deliberar
y que decidirán si condenan o no a
chavín en los tres cargos en su contra
homicidio involuntario homicidio en
segundo y en tercer grado
vamos ahora a alemania porque armin la
sed del partido de la canciller alemana
angela merkel será el candidato del
bloque conservador a la cancillería las
elecciones generales del próximo 26 de
septiembre después de que el otro
aspirante el derechista marcus todas se
retirará esta mañana de la carrera solo
el presidente de la unión social
cristiana csv reconoció una conversación
una comparecencia que la chet del
presidente de la unión
cristianodemócrata cdu cuenta con el
apoyo mayoritario de la dirección del
partido matriz previamente hablamos con
nuestro corresponsal en berlín tomas de
sparrow quien desde berlín justamente
nos contó si la ch tiene posibilidades
de ser el próximo canciller de alemania
tiene posibilidad después la sede líder
al bloque conservador en alemania que no
solamente ha estado en el poder durante
los últimos 16 años sino que también
lidera en las encuestas aunque en las
últimas semanas ha sufrido bastante por
diferentes conflictos internos sin
embargo la chet no tiene garantizada su
llegar
a la cancillería en septiembre no
solamente porque él es un candidato
relativamente poco popular por ejemplo
se le compara con marcus es ahora el
líder bávaro pero también porque asume
ese bloque conservador y asume esa
cancillería en momentos en que el bloque
está muy dividido como quedó en
evidencia en las últimas semanas así que
si bien la hace parte como favorito no
está garantizado que él vaya a ganar las
elecciones de septiembre 26 justo
corresponsal también nos explicó qué
posibilidades tiene annalynne havard
bokko candidata del partido de los
verdes frente a la cidh escuchemos
claro es que el partido verde va a jugar
un rol muy importante en las elecciones
de septiembre y de hecho en por primera
vez presento a un candidato o una
candidata en este caso asumir el rol de
canciller se trata de anna lenna pero
con una política muy joven de 40 años
que colidera el partido verde y como ya
mencioné el partido verde tiene todas
las posibilidades de jugar un rol muy
importante en las elecciones de
septiembre es el segundo partido más
popular detrás del bloque conservador
así que es muy probable que o sea el
socio minoritario de una coalición o si
las encuestas siguen favoreciendo la
incluso puede ser un gobierno liderado
por los verdes por primera vez en la
historia de alemania hablamos ahora de
américa latina' en cuba el partido
comunista eligió al presidente miguel
díaz canel como sucesor de raúl castro
en el puesto de primer secretario del
partido la sucesión marca el fin de seis
décadas de los hermanos fidel y raúl
caso como jefes del único partido del
país no obstante la familia caso
continúa en los principales cargos de la
política de este país insular informe
andrew a mayo
miguel díaz-canel árboles
un día simbólico pero que no cambia el
poder del partido comunista como partido
único de cuba' los castros le dan paso a
una generación más joven designada por
ellos mismos por lo que no
necesariamente es más flexible raúl
castro- de 89 años se retiró para ceder
su cargo de primer secretario del
partido comunista cubano al presidente
de la nación miguel díaz canel gracias
por el ejemplo el empuje la fuerza y la
confianza gracias por estar y ayudarnos
a creer en nosotros mismos fue
importante muy importante su apoyo de
aliento durante estos años de
aprendizaje y formación que nos permiten
asumir las responsabilidades en las que
usted y fidel hicieron victoria el
secretariado del partido comunista
cubano cambió por completo su
composición y el nuevo órgano será
integrado por 14 personas 3 menos que el
anterior en las calles mientras unos
celebran el nuevo nombramiento otros
creen que todo seguirá igual
vivimos orgulloso por la selección que
hizo que hizo raúl quien te deje o hasta
en él
primer saque del partido y presidenta
república la única
para mí
el traspaso de poder llega en un momento
crítico para cuba sumida en su peor
crisis económica en 30 años bajo el
efecto de la pandemia de kobe 19 y el
fortalecimiento del embargo
estadounidense impuesto desde 1962
muchos cubanos están cansados de la
escasez las largas esperas para obtener
productos importados en un 80% y a
través de las redes sociales los más
jóvenes expresan cada vez más sus
frustraciones con el gobierno comunista
en francia el gobierno está analizando
opciones para poner en funcionamiento un
pasaporte sanitario digital que facilite
las posibilidades de viajar y de acceder
a espacios de entretenimiento esto de
cara a la reapertura y a la temporada de
verano una de las propuestas se centra
en actualizar la aplicación de rastreo
de coronavirus para que muestre los
resultados de las pruebas y las vacunas
aplicadas
viajar durante la pandemia es cada vez
más fácil en francia ahora los viajeros
pueden presentar un resultado negativo
de la prueba a través de una aplicación
de rastreo conocida como todos contra el
kobe y a partir de la semana que viene
también se podrá usar para mostrar las
vacunas aplicadas una nueva función
llamada cartera permite a los usuarios
reunir todos los documentos sanitarios
en una carpeta pronto se probarán los
vuelos a córcega si a los territorios
franceses de ultramar posible me parece
bien que haya una aplicación que
centralice toda esa información es más
claro y práctico estaría dispuesto a
usarla siempre y cuando sepa quién
tendría acceso a mis datos necesitaría
saber que se toman medidas concretas
para que mis datos sean confidenciales
se espera que la nueva función trabaje
así los centros de salud autorizados
para hacer pruebas y vacunar envían los
resultados a la seguridad social
francesa una vez verificados la
seguridad social francesa envía los
documentos a los usuarios a través de un
mensaje de texto entonces los usuarios
pueden subirlos a la app que genera un
código específico para el usuario y que
tendrá que escanear antes de viajar en
france
algunos debaten si el pasaporte podría
utilizarse para algo más que viajar para
entrar en festivales e incluso en
restaurantes pero por ahora el gobierno
dice que sólo se utilizará en
determinados casos bosque intenso y tabú
no creo que sea una buena idea utilizar
este tipo de aplicación para entrar en
un restaurante o una tienda pero podría
considerarse para eventos con gran
afluencia de público la cuestión pues a
medida que se acercan las vacaciones de
verano a francia espera que la app
facilite los viajes y permita levantar
las restricciones en casa
hablamos ahora las tensiones entre rusia
y la comunidad internacional en medio la
espectativa por el crítico estado de
salud del líder opositor alexéi navalni
quien fue trasladado a un hospital
carcelario en su tercera semana de
huelga de hambre
eeuu llamó a consulta a su embajador en
moscú
joe sullivan después de que el mismo
gobierno ruso le aconsejará que partiera
hacia su país
además los 20 diplomáticos expulsados de
la embajada república checa- e moscú
llegaron en la noche del lunes a praga
su expulsión se dio en respuesta a la
misma medida del gobierno checo
y continuamos con nuestra serie para
ilustrar el próximo viaje de la zona out
a francés thomas pesquet con la cabeza
en las estrellas hacia la estación
espacial internacional hoy en tras 24
les contamos cuáles son los retos más
difíciles que pueden determinar el
destino de la estación espacial
internacional veamos
ya como para entender como el space six
se convirtió en un factor importante en
la carrera espacial tenemos que
remontarnos a los inicios de la estación
espacial internacional
[Música]
al principio todo estaba diseñado para
el programa de transbordadores de eeuu
las naves espaciales rusas soyuz eran
bienvenidas pero sólo tenían una quinta
parte de la capacidad de sus homólogas
estadounidenses
todo cambió el 1 de febrero de 2003
cuando el transbordador estadounidense
columbia explotó durante su regreso a la
tierra tras ello durante dos años y
medio los transbordadores se
suspendieron la estación espacial entró
en modo de supervivencia con suministros
limitados
el programa se convierte oficialmente
muy peligroso muy frágil y muy caro el
entonces presidente george w.bush
decidió detenerlo
en 2011 el transbordador fue retirado
del servicio y la nasa se puso a buscar
empresas que le proporcionarán un
reemplazo para llevar bienes y
astronautas a la estación espacial
internacional
[Música]
con su cápsula dragón y su cohete falcon
9 el space yx intervino y en mayo de
2012 la empresa de el on mars celebró su
primer vuelo a la estación desde
entonces el falcon 9 ha realizado 110
lanzamientos con éxito muy por encima de
sus competidores
de los 9 a ganador además fue el cohete
propulsor reutilizable que redujo
drásticamente los costos y aumentó los
lanzamientos como al principio todo el
mundo era ligeramente escéptico con
spacex progresivamente lo vimos al
recuperarse después era muy utilizado
hay un lanzador que se ha usado por
novena vez eso significa que van a
cumplir su objetivo de usar la misma
plataforma para por lo menos 10 misiones
la cápsula para el viaje de thomas
pesquet ya fue usada en un vuelo de
prueba el año pasado el lanzador se
ocupó en enviar un equipo anterior a la
estación gestiona un equipo al ver la
estación
el ejercicio de la profesión
periodística está parcialmente bloqueado
en al menos 130 países así lo anunció
este martes reporteros sin fronteras en
su informe anual sobre la libertad de
prensa en américa latina' los cinco
países peor calificados son cuba que
nuevamente se encuentra en el puesto 171
de la lista el único país de
latinoamérica que califica como muy
difícil para ejercer el periodismo
seguido de honduras que baja tres
puestos venezuela también baja la lista
el informe critica la desinformación
propagada por el gobierno de nicolás
maduro respecto a los medicamentos para
tratar el cob y 19 en rojo también se
encuentran méxico y colombia- que
perpetúan las amenazas de muertes y
agresiones a sus reporteros el sábado
sufrió la caída más significativa a 8
puntos debido a que los periodistas
tienen muchas dificultades para obtener
información sobre la gestión de la
pandemia por parte por otra parte brasil
retrocede cuatro posiciones y entra en
la zona roja calificada como difícil a
continuación lo que dice el secretario
general de reporteros sin fronteras
la copa américa latina es el continente
donde ha habido la mayor degradación
este año de la libertad de prensa sea
que no sólo que el descrédito
sobre todo a causa de coronavirus varios
jefes de estado maduro en venezuela
evolucionar en brasil han propagado
falsas informaciones incluso sobre la
pandemia o han acusado a los periodistas
de propagar falsas informaciones de
okupas y difusión formación así
finalizamos entradas 24 pero ustedes
también pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
allí encontrarán información en inglés
francés árabe y español sobre el
acontecer internacional nos vemos más
adelante como de lo que hemos preparado
para ustedes quédense con nosotros
[Música]